foreign
I was working from my laptop from a
beautiful beach in Bali
drinking water right out of a fresh
coconut and enjoying the warm Ocean
Breeze and I'm thinking
something was still missing and I
couldn't put my finger on it
how could I be in this scenario and not
feel fulfilled
I worked from 12 countries in 12 months
that year an opportunity that was once
rare is now more possible for more
people than ever before
Spotify recently introduced their new
work from anywhere policy in which
they're giving employees a choice of
working wherever they do their most
focused and creative thinking
dropbox's new way of working is called
virtual first in which remote work will
be the primary experience for employees
saving in-person meetings for special
occasions
and that's great news because over 50
percent of people that work remotely say
that if their current company doesn't
give them some type of remote work
option long term they'll look for a job
at a company that does
well problem solved right
except what people are saying and what
they're doing is inconsistent
in fact according to a recent McKinsey
study workplace flexibility wasn't even
one of the top five reasons people quit
their jobs in the past year
more freedom at work doesn't mean more
fulfillment
let me take you back to the end of 2018.
I'm two years into doing my job as the
Director of talent development for a New
York based tech company and I'm doing
what I love to do the most creating and
launching employee development programs
from scratch
and then my boss says to me next year is
going to be the year of Maintenance
focusing on refining existing programs
instead of launching new ones
I'm not a maintenance mode person while
I understand its importance it's really
not where I shine
so I wasn't looking forward to the year
ahead
meanwhile I was reading new research on
the future of work and all signs were
pointing to a remote and hybrid work
future
we now know that the pandemic
accelerated that by at least a decade
I even found a work and travel program
that coordinates a group of
professionals to work remotely from
around the world with co-working spaces
and living accommodations in each City
I was immediately hooked I had always
wanted to travel for a longer period of
time but I thought I'd have to quit my
job in order to do that
then I thought well I could do
maintenance mode from anywhere and given
my current companies Global expansion
plans I knew I had to think about where
current and future employees could be
located if I could convince my company
that I should work remotely to better
understand the opportunities and
challenges that remote workers face
it could be a win-win for both of us
and a month later I ended my apartment
lease sold my furniture and hopped on a
one-way flight from cold and snowy New
York City to Lima Peru to start my
year-long trip with my cohort and let me
tell you those first few months were
incredible
I attended a virtual team meeting for my
co-working space at Lima before heading
out to go surfing at sunset on a regular
Tuesday
I launched a work program from inside of
a pool in Puerto Escondido Mexico
and I negotiated a contract from a cafe
in Hanoi Vietnam before jumping on the
back of a motorbike to go eat buncha
with friends
I met remote workers and digital Nomads
from around the world
each of us had a different story of how
we got there
some had just been divorced or gotten
out of long-term relationships and
convinced their employers to let them
work remotely so that they could get
away
there were three corporate lawyers who
all hated their jobs and thought that
doing them from a beach would make it
more tolerable
and some just wanted to be as far away
from micromanagement and office Politics
as possible
but still after a few months when that
honeymoon period was over and the
novelty faded
we realized that traveling was just a
Band-Aid solution for the real problems
I wondered how could we get this work
from anywhere life right
so I interviewed dozens of remote
workers I conducted a focus group and I
surveyed hundreds of people and you know
what I saw in all that data wherever you
go there you are
if you hate your job in Houston you will
hate it in Hanoi what really needs
fixing is your motivation to do the work
itself
we believe we need a certain amount of
money to create or maintain the
lifestyle that we've envisioned
we think we need a specific job title
that aligns with the identity that we or
our parents imagined for us a decade ago
and we don't realize that we get stuck
in the Motions of work routines without
intention
minimizing these pressures around your
money identity and routines and focusing
on opportunities for more growth impact
and joy is the key to a more fulfilling
career no matter where you're located
and the good news is that you might not
have to overhaul your career or life to
feel fulfilled
Esther perel world-renowned
psychotherapist and couples counselor
says that in the west today most of us
are going to have two or three marriages
or committed relationships and some of
us are going to do it with the same
person
think about that for a second she's
saying that some of us will build and
experience a new relationship with the
same person
perhaps something similar could be said
about your relationship to your work at
the same company
perhaps after a challenging time an
enticing external offer or having been
together for a while instead of breaking
up you could find and create a better
path forward together
and I'm not saying you're going to get
everything you want out of your current
job but given how much time you spend
working isn't it worth a shot to make it
as fulfilling as possible
when the pandemic hit and much of the
world went remote I saw my corporate
friends in the states follow the exact
same trajectory that we did abroad the
thrill of working home in your pajamas
having more flexibility with your
schedule being able to do the laundry in
between meetings all of which can make a
real difference in improving your daily
life
but still
once the novelty faded and the reality
set in people had to face whatever
underlying issues they'd had before the
pandemic started
when the perks of an office job were
taken away whether it was the free
snacks in the break room the water
cooler conversation with colleagues
people what people were left with was
the work itself and their motivation or
lack thereof to do it
and they began to ask themselves really
important questions do I even like my
job is this really worth my time is this
what I want to be doing
and these are great questions to ask the
problem is for way too many people they
thought they had to completely overhaul
their career or life
more people voluntarily quit their jobs
in 2021 than any other year in recorded
history
they wanted a fresh start and a new
beginning after a challenging time
here's the kicker though
almost 50 percent of the people that did
find jobs after quitting say that their
new job has not lived up to their
expectations
they found out just like we did in Peru
Mexico and Vietnam that wherever you go
there you are
perhaps you could start the next chapter
of your career in an organization that
knows you where you've built credibility
and trust and a network and where they'd
be willing to let you try things you
haven't done before
now I'm not saying you should stay in a
toxic work environment and sometimes you
do need a larger scale change like a new
job or new career
but before you make a decision that you
think will make you happier
I want you to consider that happiness is
a feeling that doesn't last
it often is what we want in the moment
and depends on external circumstances
what does last however
is fulfillment
fulfillment is richer deeper and longer
term and often takes a longer amount of
time and intention to get it
as you look to generate fulfillment
I want you to consider three questions
tied to three of its key components that
are more internally driven
the first is joy
what kind of work energizes you that
you'd love to do more of
now I want you to remember that just
because you're good at something it
doesn't mean that you enjoy doing it
so really consider what gives you a deep
feeling of contentment
next is impact
how could you provide more value to your
company or clients by doing this kind of
work
and if you're having trouble answering
that question then ask your manager your
peers or clients directly
focus on work that's in that sweet spot
of meeting both your interests and the
client's needs or the business needs
and finally growth
which knowledge or skills could you
develop through these experiences
feeling a sense of progress toward
meaningful work is one of the biggest
drivers of fulfillment
I asked myself these same three
questions when I was feeling happy yet
not fulfilled with my life working from
a beach
and I found out that I find joy in
interviewing researching and talking to
remote workers about their lives
I made a significant impact by
facilitating workshops to help them
develop their skills and their careers
and growth came in the form of me
figuring out how to distill a career's
worth of the best HR advice and
expertise into an easily digestible book
for remote workers
thousands of organizations around the
world are finally understanding the
importance of giving employees a choice
of where to work
and while being given that choice is
certainly meaningful what's even more
empowering is the Fulfillment that comes
from doing work that truly lights you up
wherever you are
thank you